salut à tous voici une petite vidéo 360
degrés alors voilà je préviens tout de
suite si vous êtes sur ordinateur vous
pouvez vous déplacer avec les flèches
normalement vous êtes vous verrez des
flèches sur youtube et si vous êtes sur
smartphone vous pourrez vous déplacer en
orientant tout simplement l'écran de
votre téléphone et donc vous pouvez
regarder tout autour de vous voilà là on
est au sud de la californie le soleil
est caché derrière ses armées va
paraître dans quelques instants le temps
que j'avance donc nous voilà je voulais
essayer un petit peu la vidéo 360 degrés
avant de faire des vidéos un peu plus un
peu plus sérieuse peut-être enfin des
vrais sketches et tout donc voilà super
beau magnifique et donc je me suis dit
en fait je me suis posé la question
pourquoi il ya 360 degrés dans un cercle
d'où ça sort est en fait c'est à dire en
théorie on sait pas trop la poire
théorie elle est astronomique
en fait si tu regardes l'ancien
calendrier perse lancé un calendrier les
babyloniens il y avait trois cent
soixante jours dans l'année
certes en gros une année tu vois c'est
ça un tour suivant les croyances on
pouvait croire que c'était un tour du
soleil le tour de la terre annoncé que
c'est le têt à la terre autour du soleil
en route à un tour et donc bah ça fait
360 parties les journées pour faire ce
tour donc tout simplement tu vois
manière triviale 360° pourquoi pas c'est
une des explications
l'autre théorie qu'on a c'est sûr le
système babyloniens en fait sur hambourg
bon temps j'ai pas trop osé regarder
leur voix la voix la mer à bas le
système babyloniens en gros l'idée c'est
on va on va faire un siècle alors la
géométrie babylonienne était vachement
basé sur les cordes mais c'était pas la
seule mais a été basée sur les cornes et
en gros si on fait un cercle
on va faire un cercle je vais juste des
pièces trépied voilà
très bien donc si je t'ai un cercle avec
ça comme rayons donc c'est à dire qu'en
gros un cercle qui fait tout ça quoi
[Musique]
comme ceci est dans ce rayon
je peux le caler en gros si fois dans
mon cercle tu peux le cas les six fois
donc je te disais mon cercle en six
parties
simplement et le truc c'est que les
babyloniens eux ils ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient pas un système décimal comme
nous donc 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 et
ensuite tout stress et à quoi il avait
un système c'est xhd si mal serre qu'ils
étaient par paquet de 60 ans fait alors
en gros au niveau de commodité pour
compte et il se pourrait en fait je
repose à ce truc là gens qui habitent
ici sont bien ils sont bien
voilà en gros avec une main il faisait
genre 1 2 3 4 5 6 et c'est pour arriver
jusqu'à 12 et avec l'autre main il
comptait les paquets de douze
en fait après les différentes théories y
en a qui disent que ça faisait 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9
tu vas suivant sur les parties de ton
doigt en fait lorsque tu avais fall
angers et donc si tu divises chaque
paquet par 60 et devance effet cyclo 60
ça fait 360 degrés et donc ça se tient
complètement qu'ils aient découper le
cercle de cette façon alors en plus de
sa 360
c'est un nombre qui peut être divisée
par plein de trucs puisqu'ils payent /
évidemment des 2 3 4 5 6 8 9 10 voix la
fête de la foi / plein de choses c'est
même un nombre abondant donc je mettrais
ce que ces inscriptions est en fait il
est possible que ce soit un petit peu un
mélange de toutes ces théories la
concordance tout ça qui fait que 360
c'est juste que ça tombe très très bien
mais donc voilà ça nous vient souviens
de nos amis les babyloniens regardez-moi
ça regardez moi j'espère que vous n'êtes
pas en train de me regarder
je suis plutôt en train de regarder ce
paysage fantastique voila voila je vais
juste vous souhaiter une très bonne
année avec ce paysage j'espère que je
vous souhaite beaucoup de beaucoup de
bonheur santé l'amour la réussite toussa
toussa toussa et on se retrouve très
bientôt
on se retrouve pas ce jeudi mais celui
d'après jeudi prochain pour une nouvelle
vidéo sur sur la chaîne donc une vidéo
classique cette fois ce sera un mal en
soi un coup de fil donc
donc voilà les amis je vous fais gros
bisous
ciao j'envoie du love et de la pisse et
checker description pour pour être des
infos ou à me suivre des choses comme ça
voilà ce kit avec ses magnifiques
couchers de soleil regardez là je vous
laisse un petit peu de temps pour
pouvoir regarder autour de vous steve
est dans sa donne pas trop envie de
calme toi cyrus calme toi
un plein temps que j'y suis bien je
continue ou un plat ou un as